un bon cadeau une bonne bouteille c'est
votre philosophie
nicolas effectivement l'alcool ça monte
à la tête et ça débris dans les
personnes et c'est important pour les
les fêtes de fin d'année noël le jour de
l'an et du coup vous pouvez aller au
bout rendre chez ce caviste les coques
du vin et à montfort l'amaury et il
présente notamment une gamme de whisky
les whiskys de différents types existent
vous pourriez par hasard à voir des
choses qui sont plutôt sur de foin coupé
la céréale la douceur où vous pourriez
avoir des chutes chose
marin que musclé plus sur des tons
salins -o day lewis qui dajla par
exemple sont typiques de cette région là
de cette façon de ce savoir-faire
écossais alors on voit que le
savoir-faire écossais c'est vraiment dur
c'est marrant je sais pas si vous vous
avez 7 tveit vous préférez plutôt le
whisky de boules ou le whisky puisqu'ils
le doudou qu'ils soient et où qu'ils
soient et bien moi je vous propose
d'aller aux états unis parce qu'en fait
en écosse on écrit whisky avec un y
mais aux états unis c'est oui ce cas on
va tester votre accent mais mickaël
pascal voilà et à votre avis à ses cris
comment du coup je ne sais pas avec un i
maintenant oui sky kayak y voilà
exactement et au risque et donc des
couvées on peut découvrir notamment les
particularités de du whisky américain là
nous serons sur quelque chose qui n'a
pas d'ordre maltais nous serons sur le
maïs le seigle le blé est alors il ya
aussi un autre alcool
le rhum c'est pas plutôt remarqué oui
mais alors on va juste leur préciser
j'ai oublié de le dire tout ça avec
modération voit bien sûr ans dans un
esprit festif mais
relations toujours avec modération et
donc leur oms et les caraïbes
c'est la chaleur les tropiques et
notamment il ya des rhums arrangés avec
une gamme aussi assez importante dans ce
magasin on propose plusieurs choix
différent si con jambes
orange dit aux ananas victoria où mon
préféré
vanille noix de macadamia mais qu'est ce
que vous faites après l'apéritif il faut
lui proposer un rameau au gingembre
oui peut-être là aussi on reste toujours
dans le côté must et du gingembre et
l'apéritif à sa table mais on passe à
table et alors qu'est ce qu'on prend à
table champagne sur open wheel pour
terminer sa lunette et alors on vous
accompagner avec quoi par exemple en
termes de nourriture alors vin blanc
fruits de mer vin rouge viandes et
fromages le champagne tout le temps
c'est à l'écouté vous propose d'écouter
les conseils de ceux cabistes pour nous
la spécialité de la maison c'est les
grands meunier et pinot meunier donc
c'est page assez inhabituel
rarement mis en avant et qui fait déjà
extrêmement fruité et avec beaucoup
beaucoup de place beaucoup beaucoup de
finesse de complexité lorsque nous a
précisé ce caviste c'est que le vin qui
vient de présenter
il est complet enfin il est polyvalent
c'est à dire qu'on peut le manger avec
du foie gras de la viande blanche du
gibier plus mais aussi la trop de
ménages en plus c'est très bien pour
éviter les maux de tête même le fromage
est alors avec le fromage il a aussi une
autre idée pour vous là on est sur la
loire avec agnès et rené mosse soit
cépage chenin donc un peu un peu la star
de la région et ce qui sera très
agréable notamment sur les brebis les
chèvres des fromages pas trop raffinée
mais l'accord l'accord est évident avec
avec saison 2 va jouer noël à vous et
toute votre famille santé et n'oubliez
pas de consommer avec modération
[Musique]
alors comme il vient de le dire surtout
avec modération et je vous propose une
dernière petite curiosité c'est un c'est
un whisky japonais alors très rare est
du coup très cher à votre avis à votre
avis combien coûte cette bouteille le
quartie milliers avoir milliers d'euros
mais l'euro 2000 aux 5000 euros grégory
vous n'êtes pas loin grégory 6500 que
c'est plus aimant le vendeur m'a dit que
cette bouteille pouvait monter jusqu'à
6000 euros puis à 6000 euros
et donc c'est ça qui fait la force et la
cherté d'un alcool c'est plus il est
vieux plus à l'idée de qualité et donc
plus cher il est donc merci pour ces
quelques conseils à ses cabistes et puis
une fois de plus sans tout cela avec
modération
[Musique]